well earlier i spoke with richard
radcliffe's lawyer penny madden and i
began by asking her what she had heard
this morning
well this morning obviously hopes remain
very high
we still don't know we still haven't had
that confirmation so there is enormous
anxiety
for richard for gabriella for the family
for nazanin until she comes home on that
flight nobody will be able to relax so
still very very optimistic we don't know
what the delay is we're very very scared
but but remain ever optimistic
and when did you last talk to richard um
i've been in contact with richard this
morning he is uh excited but that's
tinged with the anxiety we don't have
any he doesn't have any visibility into
what's happening at the moment
but we just hope for good news
and where is he is he still in the uk
yes he is in the uk
and what about gabriella has she gone to
school today or is she too excited um
gabriella's very excited but i think
it's important to uh for everybody to
keep it very measured um that excitement
has got to be tempered with some
expectation we've been here before
obviously not at this level but we have
had high hopes which have been dashed
we're just trying to remain very calm um
and and keep
abreast of what's happening
obviously richard uh has been in touch
with nazanin and he is trying to control
a very excited seven-year-old who just
wants her mummy to come home
i bet she's excited
as you say we have been here before
though it has been an extraordinary
difficult six years
for for all of the family but but for
richard especially um how has he managed
to to to keep his sanity over this time
and continue to fight
at times of enormous uncertainty
uh as you say richard has campaigned
tirelessly and has remained ever calm
i don't know personally how he's managed
to do it i think he's been just very
very focused on looking for the next
opportunity to campaign to raise
awareness to win the hearts and minds of
the british public who've been terrific
in their support
and to really keep the government honest
and to keep the government working and
to make sure that this was the highest
priority that the government had to
bring his wife home
did
his initial advice from the government
was not to put his head above the
parapet to let
the diplomats let the politicians deal
with it he he took that for a short
period of time but but in retrospect was
it right for him do you think to come
out and and publicly make this this a
case that everybody in the uk now knows
about
i think he was absolutely right to do so
as you say there was conflicting advice
a lot of
foreign office officials probably much
preferring be quiet say nothing let a
time take its course one will never know
whether the course of history would have
been different but i think he's
absolutely right to have raised the
public profile of the terrible ordeal
that his wife has gone through and and
to keep her alive in the hearts and
minds of people across the country
if if this is true and and she has been
released and and and she's potentially
on her way home
and how much of it is to do do you think
with with the politics of what's
happening
in russia unfortunately and and the fact
that the uk government now has to turn
its attention to to perhaps other
sources of oil
i think it's impossible to tell but what
i would say is that there certainly
seems to be a real uh renewed
and and direct focus by the government
on making sure that this is resolved in
making sure that the debt gets repaid uh
to the iranian authorities
and and i'm sure that this is part of a
a better relationship between britain
and iran going forward but but i
couldn't possibly say or even try to
comment on the wider political
machinations i think at the moment we're
just focused on hoping that the
government can achieve
what we are very optimistic will be the
case which is bringing her home